les candidats arrivent au compte gouttes
au bureau d enregistrement une quinzaine
seulement dans la matinée hier soir un
quart des communes de côte-d'or n'avait
aucun candidat 191 exactement ce qui
inquiète la préfecture du département
cela s'est jamais produit qu'il n'y ait
pas de candidat en revanche on est un
peu préoccupé sur le fait que les
derniers jours notamment le dernier jour
le 6 mars il y avait un véritable
embouteillage de candidats et que
certains ne puissent pas se présenter
par exemple parce que bordeaux ci serait
incomplet en effet il suffit d'une
attestation manquantes ou d'un papier
erronée réunir tous les papiers semble
être un exercice relativement compliquée
compliqué pour récupérer
les documents pour la partie
administrative qui n'existait pas il ya
six ans une obligation d'avoir une un
document emplir type cerfa et un
document récupéré en mairie comme quoi
nous sommes bien inscrits sur les listes
électorales tous les candidats doivent
venir s'enregistrer c'est obligatoire
désormais et des candidats il en faut au
moins 2 un maire et un adjoint
c'est pas toujours évident dans les
petites communes de la trouver
onze personnes pour se présenter aux
élections non c'est plus des difficultés
dans ce domaine là dans la nièvre hier
soir quarante et une communes de moins
de 1000 habitants 223 comptabilisé lundi
soir dans l'yonne n'avait aucun candidat
déclaré chiffres non communiquée en
saône et loire tandis qu'en côte-d'or la
préfecture a décidé de tenir les comptes
publiquement sur le site de la
préfecture de côte-d'or on pourra
retrouver la liste des communes sans
candidat de façon à
provoquer un peu d'attention de
mobilisation des candidats et chaque
soir on réactualisera cette liste
jusqu'au 6 mars dernière journée
d'inscription des candidatures et les
candidatures enregistrées sont
officialisées dans les quatre jours
suivant leur dépôt